je vis des petites combines dans la rue
depuis l'âge de 10 ans j'ai été viré de
l'école de pilotage pour incompatibilité
d'humeur
je serai pilotes
le meilleur de la galaxie
un petit
en train de former un équipage
ça vous intéresse
ça veut dire oui
je suis sans doute la seule
à savoir
qui tu es vraiment
comment ça
tiens toi prêt
j'ai bien cru qu'on était cuit c'est bon
tu vas bien
alors ça y est c'est comme ça que ça
devait finir
[Musique]
ouais c'est parti
un piano en évidence
ça va ça va juste un peu tendu en tout
cas je te trouve très élégant je me
connais j'ai pas envie de me planter ça
fait au moins six mois que tu prépares
cette réunion tu es crif
attention j'ai une question papa une
guide papa aime qu il est exact papa va
décrocher le jackpot est gay monsieur
hire votre famille apprécié son séjour
énormément ils n'en reviennent pas de
vous nous ayez donné tous les tâches à
l'issue de votre dite de sécurité que
pensez vous de notre tour sauf votre
respect ce n'est qu'un vigile mis sur un
piédestal
je vous en prie veut pearl et la
construction la plus haute et la plus
sophistiqués au monde
vous avez bâti une ville verticale mais
vous y avez introduit tous les problèmes
de sûreté et de sécurité possibles et
imaginables
on pensait que l'état j'étais vide moi
aussi non seulement ils sont concentrés
dans ses murs mais il se trouve aussi
coincé sur une hauteur de 240 étage
personne ne peut prévoir ce qui
arriverait en cas d'incident mais je ne
suis qu'un vigile sur un piédestal alors
qu'est ce que j'en sais après tout
qu'est-ce qu'il ya le 96e est en peau
tout va bien se passer ces premiers
[Musique]
non non non non dis moi à quel point tu
tiens ta famille
si on veut sortir d'ici il va falloir me
dire la vérité
ils n'ont pas choisi cette tour par
hasard
en ce moment la seule chose qui compte
c'est ma famille
[Musique]
tu te rappelles la première fois que tu
as vu un dinosaure sa vue blue on
n'arrive pas y croire c'est comme un
miracle quelque chose approche sur celui
du reste le du rex rex et par le diacre
[Musique]
blue vient avec moi
tu sais que tu peux pas rester ici
dur à ses couleurs
lille ça va doucement babel tout ça
c'est du passé
je suis mort ou encore bon
je veux vous montrer l'avenir quoi cette
chose si l'encré bleue
il faut nous sortir d'ici ok comment il
va comme on les aime
mission impossible fallout
votre mission si toutefois vous
l'acceptez je me tais rage on avez vous
déjà reçu celle la fin que vous
redoutiez est proche
et c'est vous qui aurez ces morts sur la
conscience les conséquences de vos
bonnes intentions
[Musique]
vous avez pris une décision difficile à
berlin une vie perdue pour en sauver des
millions cette fois c'est le monde
entier qui est en danger c'est la
mission de la cia s'il avait gardé le
plutonium
nous n'aurions pas cette conversation
toute son équipe seraient mortes
oui probablement ce sont les risques du
métier
[Musique]
tu ne sais pas de quoi tu t'es engagé tu
ferais mieux de temps là les s'il te
plaît ne me dit pas contre toi combien
de fois hunt at il été trahi par son
gouvernement désavoué mis sur la touche
combien de temps un homme comme lui
peut-il supporter ça avant de décider
que ça suffit
ça ne nous ressemble pas à l'état
peut-être qu'il est temps que ça change
[Musique]
alors comment il va tu sais comme on les
aime
qu'est ce qu'il fait je crois qu'il vaut
mieux pas regardé
[Musique]
ok tu as moins d'espoir
une perte sur le gazon
fruits
[Musique]
et associations
non
[Musique]
wickens et asseoir
je veux quoi
la famille est un devoir
[Musique]
à voir
j'ai deux choses à te dire qui pour toi
n'aurait aucun sens il
d'abord il ya eu un problème
la deuxième chose on vient de perdre la
terre oh mon dieu
tu as toute ta tête tu peux te le
promettre
[Musique]
non pour être
de notre dame
match
[Musique]
m